for their I can now announce the outcome
of the divisions of Nations relating to
the United Kingdom's withdrawal from and
future relationship with the European
Union in respective mr. Clark's motion
see customs union the eyes were 273 the
nose were 276 so the noes have it
in respect of mr. Nicholas Bowles's
motion D common market 2.0 the eyes were
261 the nose were 282 so the noes have
it
the in respect of mr. Peter Kyle's
motion II confirmatory public vote the
eyes were 280 the nose were 292 in
respect of Joanna Cherry's motion G
parliamentary supremacy the eyes were
191 the nose were 292
[Music]
this showing how honorable members
vented will be published in the usual
way on the Commons vote app and website
and in hand sir
points aboard yes the sick Tuesday point
of or deceptive state was just even mark
on a point of order mr. speaker this is
now the second time the house has
considered a wide variety of options for
a way forward it has once again failed
to find a clear majority for any of the
options and yet the results of the
house's decision on Friday not to
endorse the withdrawal agreement means
that the default legal position is that
the UK will leave the EU in just 11 days
time to secure any further extension the
government will have to put forward a
credible proposition to the EU as to
what we will do with that extra time
this house has continuously rejected
leaving without a deal just as it has
rejected not leaving at all therefore
the only option is to find a way through
which allows the UK to leave with a deal
the government continues to believe that
the best course of action is to do so as
soon as possible if the house were to
agree a deal this week it may still be
possible to avoid holding European
parliamentary elections
mr. speaker cabinets will meet in the
morning to consider the results of
tonight's vote and how we should proceed
Thank You Secretary of State point of
order the leader of the Opposition mr.
Jeremy Corbyn on a point of order it's
disappointing that no solution has won a
majority this evening but I remind the
house that the Prime Minister's
unacceptable deal has been
overwhelmingly rejected three times the
margin of defeat for one of the options
tonight was very narrow indeed and the
Prime Minister's deal has been rejected
by very large majorities on three
occasions if it's good enough for the
Prime Minister to have three chances at
her deal then I suggest that possibly
the house should have a chance to
consider again the options that we had
before us today in a debate on Wednesday
so that the house can exit where the
Prime Minister has failed in presenting
a credible economic relationship with
Europe for the future that prevents us
crashing out with No Deal